en el último vídeo vimos cómo hacemos
las sumatorias vamos a volver a
practicar les parece bien y vamos a
poner esto un poco más complicado cuánto
es tres más dos pensemos que tengo tres
limones y le vamos a sumar dos fresas
cuánta fruta tendremos en total
vamos a usar el método de contar ok
empecemos con un color diferente y es 1
2 3
45 tenemos 5 frutas
también vimos que si hacemos este mismo
ejercicio en orden inverso es decir 2 +
3 nos dará una interesante vamos a
volverlo a hacer tengo 2 limones y ahora
tengo 3 fresas
con un color distinto vamos a volver a
sumar y empezamos con 1 2 3 4 5 una vez
más tenemos 5 frutas se dan cuenta como
si invertimos los números no pasa nada
realmente vamos a tener la misma
sumatoria
vamos a hacer algo distinto vamos a
hacer una línea enorme que vamos a
utilizar durante varios ejercicios
recuerda que esta línea empieza en cero
en este caso empieza en cero pero más
adelante veremos que hay números incluso
más abajo del cero ahorita empezamos en
cero porque tenemos cero fruta
y vamos a sumar si no tengo cero frutas
y no tengo limones y fresas tengo cero
vamonos hacia la derecha y contemos 1 2
3 4
como les decía esta línea se puede ir si
quieren al 100 al 200 al 3000 al 7800 el
número que ustedes gusten pueden ser
millones y pueden ser billones y
muchísimo más a nosotros ahorita nos
conviene hasta aquí
vamos a hacer la sumatoria de nuevo 3
nos colocamos en el 3
2 recuerden que nos vamos a ir hacia la
derecha porque estaremos sumando
nos recorreremos tres más dos empezamos
en el 3 y vamos a sumar dos más uno más
dos tres más dos es igual a cinco que es
el mismo 5 que tenemos aquí
y si hacemos la siguiente sumatoria nos
colocaremos ahora en el 2 y sumaremos 3
vamos a empezar en el 2 y a la derecha 1
+ 2 + 3 es exactamente el mismo 5 que
teníamos aquí arriba al que llegamos
contando
ahora vamos a hacer unos números mucho
más grandes
cuánto será 9 más 3 podemos hacer 9
estrellas y también sumarle tres más y
contarlas así es que una dos tres cuatro
cinco
nueve estrellas verdes y ahora sumaremos
tres estrellas amarillas una dos tres
hagamos otra vez el método de conteo
vámonos con otro color para que podamos
palomear 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 12
estrellas en total
vamos a hacerlo dentro de la misma tabla
les parece bien empezamos en el 9 con
las nueve estrellas azules que tenemos y
sumaremos tres amarillas una dos tres
regresamos al mismo número 12 que es el
que tenemos aquí ahora tenemos un número
12 este número 12 tiene dos dígitos más
adelante veremos lo que son los dígitos
sin embargo hoy me interesa que vean que
son dos números un 1 más un 2 el 2 está
compuesto por un 1 más 1 2
esto es importante porque sólo teníamos
un dígito bien ahora tenemos dos y es
importante porque ahora haremos sumas
con números de dos dígitos
un ejemplo y aquí empieza la parte
interesante y la parte
divertida qué pasaría si ahora sumamos
más
ok
alguien tiene tantos dedos
podemos hacer dibujos y muchos dibujos
de frutas y de fresas y usaríamos 27
limones más 15 fresas esto nos va a
tomar para siempre lo que vamos a hacer
es dividir
estos números en columnas la primera
columna solo tiene un número la segunda
columna solo tiene un número y esta
primera columna la llamaremos de
unidades
en un ejemplo sería como si tuviéramos
monedas de peso se acuerda así de
monedas de un peso
nuestra segunda columna la llamaremos de
decenas
estas decenas son como las monedas de 10
pesos
qué significan las decenas y las
unidades si tenemos un número 27
realmente tenemos 20 + 7 es decir 7
monedas de un peso más dos monedas de 10
pesos por eso mencionábamos lo de las
unidades y las decenas dos monedas de
diez pesos son veinte más siete monedas
de un peso son siete entonces serían 27
si estamos claros vamos a hacer las
sumas por columnas y ahora es más
sencillo
tomemos únicamente las unidades 7 + 5 es
igual a
vámonos a nuestra tabla y ahí haremos la
suma empezaremos en el número 7
no hagan caso a estos números previos
vamos a usar la misma pero es un número
nuevo empezamos en el 7 y vamos a sumar
5 nos recorremos a la derecha 1 2 3 4 5
7 5 es igual a 12
tenemos dos números un 1 y un 2
ahora como respuesta este 2 pertenece a
las unidades y dentro de nuestra columna
solo tenemos espacio para un solo número
así es que pongamos las unidades también
pondremos el número 2 de las unidades y
este 1 de las decenas nos lo vamos a
llevar lo arrastraremos hacia las
decenas
ven como hemos colocado el número 12 el
1 y el 2 acá tenemos 12 una decena dos
unidades
1 y 2 es nuestro 12 digamos que los
separamos porque sólo teníamos un
espacio más adelante explicaremos bien
cómo funciona ahora tendremos una nueva
columna 1 + 2
el 1 que teníamos que hemos arrastrado
más el 2 que ya teníamos previamente y
un 1 de nuestra operación original uno
más uno las dos son tres más uno son
cuatro
ahora sabemos que uno dos más uno son
y lo colocaremos en la parte de las
decenas ahora tenemos nuestro resultado
27 + 15 es igual a 42 funciona
básicamente así pero vamos a hacer más
ejercicios les parece bien dejemos aquí
nuestra tabla en caso de que la ocupemos
más adelante y ahora sabremos cuánto es
+ 3 volvamos a hacer nuestra división
por columnas
y
esta que es de las unidades
le vamos a colocar una de unidades y a
este lado una de de decenas o de 10 y
sumemos nuestra primera columna de
unidades ocho más tres es igual a
posiblemente ya se las sepan de memoria
sin embargo vamos a volver a los números
básicos a las sumatorias pequeñas con el
88 1982 es igual a 10 8 más 3 es igual a
tenemos entonces 83 es igual a 11 y una
vez más tenemos dos dígitos
una unidad y uno de decenas colocaremos
el uno correspondiente las unidades en
la fila de unidades y este número uno de
las decenas lo arrastraremos encima del
tenemos nuestro 11 una vez más separado
en dos colocado en la misma operación
tenemos una fila nueva la cual ahora es
1 que es el 1 que arrastramos más 71 + 7
es igual a 8
entonces colocamos este 8 en las decenas
y ahora sabemos que es 78 3 es igual a
81 vamos bien no siempre tenemos
respuestas con dos dígitos a veces sólo
tenemos una y vamos a investigar cómo
funciona cuando sólo tenemos un dígito
como respuesta vamos a hacer 56 más 2
volvemos a separar nuestras columnas y
sumamos 62 sabemos que es 8
esto porque ya no los estamos
aprendiendo ya es parte de la memoria
que tenemos es un solo dígito y lo
colocamos en las unidades
ahora aquí ya no tenemos absolutamente
más nada que sumar lo dejamos en blanco
y sumamos 5 más nada es igual a 5 56 más
2 es igual a 58 para que también nos
quede un poco más claro vamos a hacer un
fragmento de la línea que normalmente
utilizamos y empecemos en el 55 54 55 56
57 58 59 y 60 para que hagamos esta
sumatoria fácil dentro de la tabla y lo
puedan hacer visual
empezamos en 56 y sumaremos 2 los
recorremos a la derecha como lo hemos
hecho porque sumamos 1 y sumamos 256 más
2 es igual a 58 que es exactamente el
mismo número que teníamos fácil cierto
de cualquier manera seguiremos
practicando en los vídeos que siguen bye